well speaking of hate did you watch the
uh boxing match this weekend yeah
oh you hated it i loved it uh locally
speaking of hate no no well
no you didn't call lopez you didn't call
lopez
i saw your post to the people yeah yeah
he did
your boy i put a grand on uh lopez you
did you did
why because you won the fight
i didn't think of you you put a grand on
it yeah but like how did you know
like five g's on uh ortega he was
underdog too
oh ufc ufc and he won damn
uh lopez i i just like that he's he's
younger
i like he's a beast i like that he uh oh
there we go look it's an old one
they hit nuts yeah but they do that
though look at that
oh that's really a thing and as i told
you it's a nut bump
yeah that's an old i don't think they're
really man they hit nuts
um yeah i think lopez just uh he's the
real deal man
lomachenko two-year layoff his last
fight wasn't great lesson rounds
campbell against campbell yeah i just i
don't know okay i wasn't feeling it i
mean
but dude that young gun he almost listen
you almost got stopped at the end
you almost lost it yeah because you got
one judge has it 119 111 uh
uh uh letterman uh julia letterman she
she should be gay
i was about to say fire her immediately
because i i ha i had lo
my girl asked me because she loves
boxing she was like what do you think i
was like
man i bet on it and i hope lopez wins he
might have won by a
one round depends i score the second but
he lost those what last
last four four four but then he won the
12th but well he almost stopped him
he almost stopped i didn't he showed me
a lot that's why i was like you give it
that's the real deal he's a real deal
at 93 years old 23 years old called he
called devin
henley the email email paper champion
that's so funny email paper channel i
had a seven
five i had a seven five uh
yeah okay so this is the this is the one
that's saying that's exactly how i added
something look at 119
the one oh she explained it that's what
it says in this video
but i don't know on here
i'm going to fast forward it yeah this
dude has seven views
yes she's not only here we have seven
she's not coming back
and a lot of shitty podcasts i'm not
saying he's bad podcast a lot of
podcasters and people do this they'll be
like breaking news oh yeah
they'll decorate the head like khabib
gives inside info and he clicked on it
it's just clickbait and again they got
it they got you they got you guys
congratulations now you know what no
judge in the history of the sport has
ever
gotten a podcast and explained their
scoring yeah they don't they don't have
to just fight somebody i don't have to
do that
that's that's a problem that's a problem
with boxing bob mann rips her
why would you have her bobby rams 9 000
that's what i'm saying seven five
minutes tenth eleventh weren't closed i
am the twelfth round
it was a good fight though it was a
great fight the best boxing fight we've
had in the long run can i go back to you
dropping five g's
on ortega that's my boy that's a lot of
money that's the homie though
yeah but he was a big underdog yeah you
just knew you felt it
i'm super biased that's why i told on
below the bell i'm like okay i'm going
to bed
and i bet china gave me a [ __ ]
hundred dollars where's my money at chin
oh he's gonna give him
no yeah
get it off your chest yeah so why five
g's why not he's such a big number
he said why not yeah it makes fight i
mean i just
fight more wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait you bet five or you won
five bat five g's one eighty
a century it's something right one
eighty four hundred i think
eighty four hundred huh that's that's
that's that's damn
that's a lot gosh well how much money
you dropped on a
well to the people that podcast uh
listen i bet y'all
dm's i know you're waiting on your cash
app um
there you go five thousand one eighty
five hundred god damn
damn plus 170 my boy come on is this off
a website
yeah straight bit wow i hope i
yeah and then i i sent you the other one
too and i said i took
uh took lopez plus 3.25
a grand one three thousand two hundred
five hundred damn
3250 sorry so you're just racking up
money this weekend
good money bet for the underdogs what
that's crazy but when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic
song